l'ars est prêt pour une hardy ou toi
harvey view guillaume depardieu
guillaume tu penses à quoi lancement à
l'homosexualité féminine ou masculine et
de l'es2 viala je me sens totalement bim
un placebo comme mec l'a pas inventé la
poudre
tu fais quoi quand tu te regarde dans la
glace le matin je crois en dieu mais
dans le mauvais sens ta plus belle
histoire d'amour c'est là qu'elle s'est
bien ça va là c'est quand la dernière
fois que tu as pleuré hier
pourquoi exécuter une chanson ouais tu
changerais quoi en tout acheter une
baguette magique tout pas la tête là à
lui bien trouve pas qu'il est beau
cynthia si charmant qu'est ce tu
pourrais dire de plus négatif sur toi
c'est un égoïste tu ferais quoi site
rester 24 heures à vivre pour un crédit
les
borloo
déjà pensé au suicide oui et alors
pourquoi tu l'a pas fait mais je les
fais pareil
qu'est ce que la vie tu as appris cela
maintenant leurs yeux rien comment
voudrais tu mourir vite tu as menti là
que tu me réponds non